going back to the test so I did the
muscle test the way it works is we were
talking about is the recoil in the
deltoid and the key part is the recoil
okay and so knowing that we asked the
question which is okay well how do we
replicate that recoil without a doctor
being present and so we created I'm
going to grab my phone yeah please yes
we created a unique whipping gesture
turn my screen off a whipping gesture
hmm
so it's actually three whips you go one
two three and we get three peaks of data
from the gyroscope and accelerometer and
what we're measuring is the recoil of
the hand whoa all throughout the wrist
the hand and the forearm are muscles and
what can you learn from just yeah three
whips I said well what that's okay so
there's two parts that there's what
we're detecting which I think was what
you're asking about but then there's how
can that be applied by a lot of
different modalities yeah yeah and the
first one we're detecting is binary it's
either stress or no stress really and
that's what we go to a black and white
level of binary what okay so what is it
about this whip that you can determine a
binary dress or no stress muscular
tension so and are you asking about how
we initially identified the same cage so
is this like is this like when I when
I'm holding it I'm tense I'm whipping it
all tense and then that's like yo this
person's stress yeah and what's
interesting about that is that you could
be like I'm tend to force it and you're
not really tense if you're not actually
really tense oh sorry if you're not
actually tense will pick up and not
actually be intense so you literally
have to be really tense you can't fake
it can't fake it yeah
okay so then yeah cuz even when I was
trying to do that I was loose but I was
faking exists I saw that in your hand
like yeah and like and you can you can
fake it to the point where you'll be
able to evoke some tension but there has
to be even if you faked it there has to
be the felt experience versus if you're
like light as a feather right it's like
trying to be like I'm tan so be like
you're super loose
it's the body of your body the sense
he's literally just asking me hey will
you whip your phone three times right
now yeah and I'm like okay one two three
and I whip it and then you guys are like
oh you show a a stress level of blank
stress no stress by there but the one
part that's important is its specific to
thought so
the way sensitive works when you show a
demo but yeah let's show this yeah cool
so so for context we just being
announces yet this app just hit the App
Store last week last week great it's
been we've been doing research for three
years so we had a research platform and
the scene oh yeah that's what it takes
to get the good stuff yeah took a while
yeah so this is it a show that can yeah
let's let song
yeah let's breathe let's bring it up
yeah let's bring it up to this one and
go ahead that's the dashboard page and
the top to the first Button says measure
how you feel okay so it's a you just hop
on that button and immediately you can
check in on your current state but it
prompts you with a question it says
think and feel I can the stress my life
I can act and hopefully manage it has a
specific statement you have to think and
feel and they manage stress live better
yeah
practice mind and body skills are
focused on improving specific areas of
your life how do you feel so then you
click on that to check in regularly have
manage your health yes you tap on this
okay how do you feel and then there's
the statement I'm able to effectively
respond to the stress in my life and if
you shake the phone a little bit you'll
see the sensor data movement so just
shake the phone a little bit move it a
little bit yeah yeah you can see the
sensor movement yeah so that's the
gyroscope that's a Jessica yeah so we
visualize the sensor gyroscope and
accelerometer data both yeah use both
our primary signal came from the
gyroscope but your primary comes from
gyroscope so yeah there it is
so uh so I will I have to be with this
so I focus on the statement thinking
feeling response I'm able to effectively
respond to stress in my life I swipe and
then I wit and I went three times and
then it processes the sensor data whoa
no no one's using yes it's going take a
second for the signal
if you it'll show up in about a second
or two you've got to turn the servers on
they're just feeling stressed I'm a
little nervous when I do public speaking
so pretty accurate and so we'll just
show you just like that and then you can
agree disagree yes if it was really
agree after reflecting yeah and that's
the non conscious part so they agree if
you're effecting is are sort of that
button is our measurement of starting to
see how many people were giving that
insights to into like something they
weren't aware of oh I see yeah so the
intention of that third button okay and
I'll agree and now the cool thing is
right so now we've identified that I'm
in somewhat of a stress state it says
explore sources of stress so now we can
identify where it's coming from down
find a safe space take a deep breath so
here's kind of some of the things that
you can do afterward yeah interesting
and then it shows up green if I do that
in the don't detects tree yeah exactly
and so explore work is the first topic
and now I can explore if it's coming
from work what I'm gonna do is go back
to our dashboard page and these are all
the topics so it you can explore all
these topics to see where the stress is
coming from Oh interesting
okay that was nice check-in from
yesterday okay so so the so the topic
options okay and then so then what you
do is you can look at work finance
well-being self-esteem joy intimacy
family flow autonomy random so then when
I let's say click on intimacy that is
the do I does that mean I have to be in
like an intimate moment or if I'm at
work I have to be at work and then I'm
measuring it no that's a good question
but it so let's click on intimacy so
intimacy opens up and it tells you how
to set context to be in a neutral state
um you just have to think about that toe
so I think I think my intimate
relationships are healthy focus on the
statement think and feel your response
and then you swipe and WIPP three times
when ready okay nice nice so so each one
of those cards has their own sentence
that's like my work is healthy or my
intimacy is healthy and then depending
on on on if that statement is is true to
you focus on say anything official sway
then whip three times already okay my
answer relationships were healthy
okay so I'll focus on it feel it okay
okay and you whip so I swiped whip one
two three that's fitted to me but let's
see if this is accurate does that feel
true it's okay
it says stress not it's this stress not
detected
I've been sacrificing a lot of wood I've
been working on with intimate
relationships for what we're building
with the show so but but at the same
time I do have healthy intimate
relationships so also this is um you
would want to do this on your own phone
because you guys true this is based on
your phone if you need to me when you
sign up there's demographic information
you give that help with the precision of
our signal so interesting so you might
get a better insight I would overall
agreed cool yeah both agree that Oh tap
agree feedback great job managing this
part of your life interesting okay cool
okay so there's there's these topics
okay interesting so then what am i what
am I the this just gives me a more
instantaneous response into feedback a
closed and back loop into how I'm
managing my stress in air in each one of
those topics of my life and it should a
percentage of the time help you
potentially identify an area you might
not be aware of that's a source of
stress and I'm really glad you hit
intimate relationships because that was
one in our early research that I hit on
that was like an eye-opener for me so we
had a baby I love so much and he was
Charlie and congratulations Charlie
Charlie it's a girl and she's the joy of
my life I guess I'm the LOX
yeah I'm screwed oh that tastes like a
couple years older like what I have one
hour but the point is is that um so
about six months after she was born I
was exploring the protocol on intimate
relationships and I you know I did the
statement I did the gesture it's a
stress not detected and I mean
my monkey brain was like I'm sorry I
said stress detected and that's what I
said immediately my my monkey brain was
like oh that's not true I want to shut
it down and then I stopped for a second
I was like no it totally is true it's
been like six months and I've totally
neglected my wife since you've had the
baby and I was completely unaware of it
and like there was total stress building
between her and I that like I am pretty
sure if they kept going would turn into
something gnarly yeah but in that moment
I stopped and I wouldn't talk to her and
I told her I was like look I just saw
stress detected on intimate
relationships like how are you feeling
and she's like yeah I definitely feel
stressed towards you and I'm like holy
[ __ ] I've had a conversation and it
literally transformed my relationship in
that moment because we also went and
changed it you know and you know got
deep and into it with each other and
yeah damn and I wasn't aware I really
wasn't aware I'm confident it would've
went on that path of like you know oh
interesting so so there's a couple
things here so first is that it it dude
doing doing our life trajectories can go
so many different ways and if we think
sometimes that things may be going
smoothly perfectly fine but we don't
necessarily know that the way that we
actually are with right one of our loved
ones can be on a trajectory that might
not be so healthy so to be able to check
in like this yeah and yeah push put
ourselves on to a healthier trajectory
yeah it's awesome